this former NFL player lost a hundred
plus pounds from water fasting for 40
days Seattle Seahawks Russell Kung
literally had nothing but water and he
said it wasn't just all about weight
loss he said he was quieting his
physical hunger and he unlocked mental
Clarity and a spiritual Revelation for a
total reset he said he's not just
lighter in weight now but that he's also
lighter in spirit okung did say that
this isn't for everyone and we're
definitely not telling you to go try it
but he did say there were a lot of other
benefits from the fast he saw his skin
and digestion improve he saw his overall
mental focus improved and he said his
joint pain decreased